[Applause]
we are
here with buzzfeed to rank all of our
songs to find out which
monsta x song is our actual
favorite
here's how it works all of our songs are
spread out in
a bracket paired against each other each
pairing
will have to decide together as a group
which song
we like more to move on to the next
round
the last song remaining will be the
winner
and our personal favorite monsta x song
oh
[Music]
okay three two
three
because it's calm and easy to sing it
makes
comfortable middle of the night versus
love yeah
oh
two
i think it makes lots of empathy
by the songs give
brave brain yeah fall in
versus send together three two
one fallen okay
[Music]
okay we got three nikes sir night view
you are trespass
we have no time three two one
transformers
who want trespass you already give us
three trips
[Music]
[Music]
versus
[Music]
one two three beautiful
[Music]
respect respect
it's cool alligator versus find you
please
do
not everything all right
[Music]
two song is very bright energy yeah
all right yeah i love killer
one two three lovely
[Applause]
okay
versus beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
of the night versus falling one two
three who's middle
middle okay two middle three we gotta
follow night view versus trespass
oh yeah one two three
cooked
[Music]
[Music]
okay i got you
[Applause]
thank you buzzfeed be sure to check out
gambler right now right now
[Music]
you